today we've had a national tragedy
in an apparent terrorist attack on our
country two airplanes have crashed into
the World Trade Center
you know have some time you just don't
want to get out there you know that was
me today everything okay yeah
[Music]
there's no one who has not been affected
by that Jeffrey what's going on of them
clue does anybody there can anybody hear
me
[Music]
guys we got 32 elevators off the grid
all the upper floors are gone Wow and if
you're but Miffy is pretty maybe you're
not going to believe this how are you
we're still in the North Tower can you
please have a call my wife me too mom
listen listen to me
people that were stuck on the elevator
at that point you pretty much in your
own conference just happened to be
sharing it I think we're under attack
the explosion fell from the South Tower
so when something tragic happens your
heart and your soul latch on to what
really matters you don't know me I'm
calling you for your husband he wanted
you to know that if you know the story
about really honoring those that didn't
make it building now and those that did
you
you